Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
full justice league snyder cut breakdown video
easter eggs and all the differences between
this in the theatrical cut it's basically a
completely different movie the story plays out in
a very different way so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i will be doing
more snyder cut videos in the next couple of
days there's also another alternate version of
the justice league snyder cut that zack snyder is
releasing in the next couple of weeks called the
justice is grey edition is basically going to be
a black and white version of the snyder cut but
it will have some slightly different joker scenes
so technically it is like a fully alternate cut so
there are two alternate cuts of the justice league
snyder cut i don't know exactly when that's going
to happen but i will do a video for it when
they do release it but careful for spoilers
for the snyder cut if you have not watched the
movie yet i'm assuming most of you have by now
most of the basic storyline plays out similar to
the theatrical cut storyline but there are many
new story elements subplots teasers for sequel
stories for the characters like justice league
2 justice league 3 as well as future solo movies
and teasers for the characters that they would
have originally done for instance there's like a
whole new cyborg movie worth of footage that was
added back in and completely changes his character
in the film he's like the heart of the film now
the epilogue itself is almost like its own justice
league 2 sequel short film just attached to the
end of the first movie it's like a full 30
minutes long so what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to focus on the major differences
like the biggest changes throughout the movie
because otherwise this would be like a six hour
video but just starting with the prologue so they
do have a proper prologue at the beginning of the
movie because the movie is divided into different
chapters there are technically six chapters total
but that's also considering the epilogue so really
it's more like five chapters in the epilogue
but the prologue opens with a combination of
batman v superman footage of superman's
death that they've added extra context to
now you see that superman's screams create shock
waves that resonate across the entire earth that
can be heard by all the major side characters even
the amazons back on even the atlanteans underneath
the water we learned that the three mother boxes
that darkseid lost to the forces of earth in the
flashback had been lying dormant this whole time
just waiting to contact darkseid and the forces
of apokolips because they were afraid of superman
and potential kryptonians that's how powerful he's
supposed to be relative to darkseid and the other
new gods characters like steppenwolf so superman's
death cries let the mother boxers know that it's
safe to reactivate themselves and they send out
basically what amounts to a homing beacon sort of
alerting the forces of apokolips to where they are
in the universe because as we learned later in the
film apparently when darkseid came to earth found
the anti-life equation hidden on the planet then
promptly got his ass beat by the old gods with the
help of the amazons the humans the atlanteans
the green lantern corps he left and for some
reason lost all records of where earth was located
which i think is more of a story twist to explain
why darkseid is only just now coming for
the mother boxes in the anti-life equation
many thousands of years later because if he had
remembered where earth was he would have come
back thousands of years ago but it's steppenwolf
that hears the mother boxes calling to them first
so that's why he shows up first before darkseid
hears them so he comes to earth to collect them
hoping that with them darkseid will allow him
to return home there's this whole subplot with
darkseid that's completely different that i'll
explain when we get to those parts of the film
completely changes his character as well not only
physically but his backstory as well but then we
begin with chapter one which is titled don't count
on a batman which is a reference to aquaman's
dialogue when he turns down his offer to join the
justice league even after he gives the town a fat
stack of cash but we get a bunch of brand new
scenes of batman traveling to the frozen north
to recruit aquaman for the justice league alfred
says he's not for two after he returns with a no
meaning that he also asked wonder woman before
this and she at least at first said no but she
does come around later there are a ton of new
side characters in this nordic fishing village
that we meet and we get more subplot about aquaman
visiting all the villages all over the north like
this to give them aid just him being a good person
sort of setting up the idea that even though he's
very brusk he's a very grumpy personality
he does do a lot of good things and sort
of setting up the concept of him being the future
king of atlantis or the rightful king of atlantis
remember the events of the justice league movie
take place before the aquaman movie so he's not
king right now when batman is meeting him for
the first time all the character interactions are
very different they turn all these villagers into
much bigger characters we get a full traditional
icelandic song that they sing to aquaman sort
of setting up the idea that they kind of worship
him like a god king but then you get a bunch of
new beats with side characters like martha kent
losing the kent farm really the next big scene
the big difference scene is of lois lane visiting
superman's monuments he takes coffee to the police
officer on duty that's guarding it and it's a big
cameo scene it's the actor who originally played
jimmy olsen in the christopher reeve superman
movies now he also had a cameo in the theatrical
cut but because they cut this scene his cameo was
changed to be the prison guard in iron heights
when the flash was going to visit his father
the first scene with wonder woman is essentially
the same but goes down in a very different way
it's much longer there's way more slow-mo there's
no gratuitous ass shots in slo-mo like she is a
character is not sexualized quite as much during
the snyder cut as she was during the theatrical
cut and she kills all these attackers very
violently you can even see the blood splatters
when she bashes them against the wall so remember
this is meant to be rated r the snyder cut is
rated r mostly for violence in the three i believe
f-bombs that happened during the movie the first
death bomb comes during this scene during the
attacker scene the second one is from cyborg when
he meets wonder woman and the third one is from
the flash forward nightmare scene when batman is
threatening the joker bet you never thought that
you would see batman dropping an f-bomb in a big
movie but then we get a very different version of
the steppenwolf scene coming to take the amazon's
motherbox the basic storyline is similar but it
all plays out in a very different way obviously
the major change though is steppenwolf himself not
only did they completely redesign his character
this is what zack snyder originally wanted him
to look like the studio said no so interestingly
enough zack snyder was the person who created this
version of steppenwolf but when they greenlit the
snyder cut last year he said that part of the
terms of him coming back to do it was that he
would be able to do things how he originally
wanted them to do it so they basically reversed
steppenwolf to look like he originally wanted
him to before the studio made him change it
but the other big difference with steppenwolf is
that his story in his dialogue in the movie is
completely different across the entire film all
of his new scenes make him feel like a much more
credible threat especially this opening scene
with him you understand his motivation more his
backstory and his relationship with darkseid he's
just more of a character in general then we begin
with chapter 2 which is titled the age of heroes
which is a reference to the big flashback scene
the literal age of heroes later wonder woman
also has the dialogue where she talks about the
age of heroes coming again but it begins with
steppenwolf going to the russian reactor site
there's a new scene that kind of explains why he
chose this site specifically because it's a place
with a lot of nuclear waste and fallout radiation
he says it's toxic that's good basically what's
happening is they're terraforming earth into
a version of apokolips and the idea is that
the toxic environment more closely resembles the
environment on apokolips so it's easier for them
to change this part of the earth then we get a
totally new scene of wonder woman discovering
the amazon's warning arrow and using it inside
the amazonian temple to learn the full story of
darkseid the amazons basically painted a darkseid
tutorial powerpoint presentation thousands of
years ago after the darkseid war for whoever would
discover the warning arrow should they need to use
it so it didn't have to be wonder woman finding
the arrow to enter that secret room it's just that
there was no one left in the world of humans who
remembered the true meaning behind the signal fire
at the temple but then we eventually meet ryan
choi who was totally cut out of the theatrical
version at starlapse he winds up taking over the
lab at the end of the movie and they sort of set
him up for an atom origin story in the future
sequels the flash movie the cyborg solo movie
that they would have originally done but here's
the thing zack snyder also revealed that he had
been pitching a spin-off movie with the atom set
in china to the studio so they would have done a
full-blown adam movie originally but he said the
studio turned him down we get a different version
of the scene of aquaman saving that fisherman then
going back to atlantis just to look at the statue
of king atlan and meeting with volkow who was
also completely cut out of the theatrical version
this whole speech of volkos is also meant to
set up the events of the aquaman solo movie
then we get a totally new scene of steppenwolf
using the mother box to contact assad back on
apokolips and let him know that he's found the
mother boxes and is in the process of reclaiming
the other two indisad also narrates most of
their shared history of the new gods explaining
why steppenwolf was exiled from apokolips if it
wasn't clear from their conversation he tried
to usurp the throne from darkseid and then he
clarifies also that he is darkseid's family
technically steppenwolf is darkseid's uncle for
his crimes he was sentenced to capture and convert
many many thousands of worlds he's still got 50
000 worlds on his sentence before he's allowed to
return to apokolips but his whole motivation in
the movie for all this is that he just wants to
come home so this is sort of like a big side quest
for him then we get a brand new version of the
darkseid war flashback scene when she's explaining
to batman what happened with darkseid himself back
in the movie the fight plays out mostly the same
as the theatrical cut but it's a longer version of
the war with a couple different characters you get
more footage of the old gods this is zeus this is
aries we get a slightly different version of the
green lantern scene with yalan gur i love that
they have this moment with darkseid trying to grab
the green lantern ring before it takes off back to
owa but the whole symbol that spawns out of the
ground when darkseid strikes it with his weapon
is the anti-life equation itself revealing itself
inside the earth it's hidden on planet earth
that's why earth is such an important target
for him zack snyder has only talked a little
bit about this storyline in connection with the
sequels and how the anti-life equation was used
but in the snyder cut darkseid explains he's going
to use it to conquer the entire multiverse so he
was going to introduce the concept of the
multiverse for the first time in the dceu
during this movie now we will see a version of the
multiverse during the upcoming flash flashpoint
movie but it won't be zack snyder's vision of the
multiverse it'll be a little bit different however
it will be the way that they keep the snyder
cut in canon with all the new dc movies they're
also using the flash movie in the multiverse to
canonize the events of all the classic dc movies
like christopher reeves superman christian bale's
batman the dc tv stuff like the crisis on infinite
earth's crossover scene with ezra miller's flash
and grant gustin's flash and just for reference
the events of that crossover scene take place
after the events of the justice league movie
because during it ezra miller's flash references
long conversations he's had with cyborg about the
existence of the multiverse which implies they've
been working together for a good long while
but then we move into chapter 3 which is titled
beloved mother beloved son which is a reference
to cyborg's mother and his death or his recorded
death in the car accident before his father turned
him into cyborg using the mother box you have
to imagine legally the world thinks that victor
stone died because his father can't reveal what he
did with the mother box then there's a totally new
scene of the flash introduction with ezra miller's
version of iris west she's also coming back in the
flash movie too so it'll be the same iris west
i'm not sure why he's so hot to get a job as a
dog walker if he's trying to earn fast cash there
are a lot of legit legal jobs that he could do to
earn money way faster but they mostly play it for
comedy especially with the hot dogs in the puppies
the flash is mostly used for comedic relief
in the snyder cut just like the theatrical cut
but all the jokes themselves are different there's
a big easter egg on this truck too gardner fox was
actually the comic book creator who created the
golden age jay garrick flash which is why zack
snyder used his name here even though technically
they're introducing the barry allen version of
the flash i'm sure there'll be a bunch of jay
garrick easter eggs during the flash movie when
we eventually see that i was a little disappointed
though when they have this burger scene and he
didn't use big belly burger just use some generic
burger brand seems like a missed opportunity
there's a couple extra atlantean scenes here just
setting up steppenwolf coming to take their mother
box like he drags all these atlanteans out of the
ocean then uses this apokolips tech to extract
memories directly from their minds then you get
the first half of the cyborg origin story with
him flashing back to the football game we meet
his mother we see them get in the car accident
his father vows to save his life at any cost
later in the movie he narrates the rest where
we watch the mother box turn him into cyborg as
he continues telling the other justice league
members how he became cyborg there's almost like a
small short film sequence for him just narrated by
his father where you see how he's connected to all
these machines they kind of explain his abilities
zack snyder visualizes it in a very specific
way eventually you see him use his skills to
give this giant fat stack of cash to the waitress
in her bank account throughout the film there are
a couple scenes where he discusses talking to
machines like he talks to batman's ship the ship
says that it wants to fly there's a software issue
i think i can fix it then there's a very different
version of the flash scene with him meeting his
father at iron heights where he references his
mother's death and his father being framed all
setting up the flashpoint reverse flashback story
and even though they're doing a version
of flashpoint for the upcoming flash movie
i don't know if they plan on including a big
version of reverse flash because the story sounds
like it's going to be very different from the
comic book flashpoint story they haven't really
said yet but eventually at some point we will see
the dceu reverse flash in a future flash story
interestingly enough though we found out that
zack snyder did not plan on making reverse
flash a member of lex luthor's in justice
league during justice league two and three
it would have been captain cold instead there's a
different version of his scene meeting batman for
the first time they get rid of all the k-pop music
in the entire soundtrack for the movie in general
all the pop songs are different junkie xl did
the new score it's available on spotify right now
i feel like it suits the tone of the snyder
cut way better than the theatrical cut anyway
there's a brand new scene of wonder woman in
alfred where he sets up the idea of batman's
energy absorbing gauntlets that he uses during the
superman fight scene wonder woman also asks him
to make a new lasso of the same material in black
of course alfred also tries to take her to school
on the proper tea brewing technique even though
she's 5 000 years old they also do clarify in
the movie that she is 5 000 years old which is
how long ago the darkseid wore flashback scene
is supposed to have happened meaning that zeus and
hippolyta would have probably conceived her some
time after this battle around the time he was
getting ready to create themyscira before ares
full-blown civil war amongst the old gods then
we get another really big scene with steppenwolf
getting the vision of the anti-life equation
from the mother boxes alerting dasad and then
him transferring the zoom call so to speak to
darkseid himself darkseid has entered the chat
and you get that big explainer where he tells
steppenwolf about conquering the multiverse with
the anti-life equation as we move to chapter 4
change machine which is a reference to the mother
box the reason why they say they call it that is
because that's basically what the mother box does
it rearranges matter according to the wishes of
its master who is darkseid the reason why they're
able to use it to resurrect superman though is
because one cyborg can sort of hack it to make
it think that they're darkseid giving it orders
but also because the mother box itself sort of
rearranges his kryptonian dna his molecules into
that of a healthy kryptonian so sort of reversing
all the damage that he took during the doomsday
fight the whole fight scene with steppenwolf in
the cooling tower though goes down mostly the
same with some minor changes zack snyder uses
some different flash jokes some of the action
scenes are a little bit different but the next
really major new scene is martian manhunter martha
kent going to see lois lane martha manhunter they
reveal that martian manhunter has secretly been
walking around as general swanwick this whole time
this scene is mostly though about him getting
lois to go back to work at the daily planet and
set up the ending scene where he comes to reveal
himself to batman there's a slightly different
version of the superman resurrection scenes first
flash tells cyborg that superman is his hero
then when they're breaking into the kryptonian
ship they walk past all of his suits like they
recognize his body and think that he's there to
get another suit so they just open all those cages
i'll talk about these different suits a little bit
when we get to the part where superman actually
comes back to grab the black suit but also while
they're breaking into the ship there's a cutaway
scene with lois lane that shows she's pregnant
with superman's child and the storyline was
meant to play a big role in the sequels but
in justice league 2 like as we're still kind
of going through the story in this first timeline
we would have found out that eventually lois lane
has a relationship with batman but darkseid would
have eventually killed her and the baby breaking
superman leaving him vulnerable to the anti-life
equation and turning him into the nightmare evil
superman you see in the epilogue ending scene but
after the flash travels back in time and correctly
warns batman to save lois they fixed the timeline
and defeat darkseid batman was eventually going
to sacrifice himself in when lois and superman's
baby was born they were gonna name him bruce in
honor bruce wayne and the child wouldn't have
had any of superman's abilities he would have
just seemed like a normal human but in 20 years
zack snyder revealed that he would become the next
batman in a sort of batman beyond terry mcginnis
scenario but you have to imagine that bruce and
alfred probably would have made sure that baby
bruce kent batman would have access to all of his
wealth in his batman tech although because we have
characters like cyborg now working together with
the justice league creating new hypertech you have
to imagine that bruce kent's future tech version
of batman would be vastly more advanced than the
tech that ben affleck's batman used but i did love
the way during this version of the scene that
the kryptonian ship just completely flips out
because it extrapolates the nightmare timeline
probabilities like nope this is definitely going
to end badly please don't do this the motherbox
gives cyborg the vision of the potential nightmare
future it's one of the potential nightmare
timelines later the joker and the epilogue claims
that there's been multiple timelines they've
tried multiple times to fix the timeline but
in the nightmare scenes you see darkseid and evil
superman going around killing all the members of
the justice league like you see the dead version
of kilwa green lantern here of the hall of justice
with batman's cow implying that he's killed him
and you notice that the joker's playing card
that he gave the batman has been ripped meaning
that batman at some point in the future called
off their truce and probably wound up killing
joker himself as he said he would eventually
do in the epilogue the superman fight scene goes
down a little differently there's no do you bleed
line thankfully no awkward cg mustache removal
there's a brand new scene of steppenwolf coming
to take the motherbox and cyborg's father dying
sacrificing himself while marking the mother box
allowing them to track it then there's the totally
new scene of superman going back to the kryptonian
ship to get his black suit which is a nice comic
book deep cut for the return of superman zack
snyder also said that he tried to sell the studio
on a mullet for superman to do the full comic
book easter egg but the studio was like no way
you get to do the mullet you also see the other
kryptonian suits that he has on the ship there's
a full warframe suit from the comics there's a
traditional house of l armor suit like jor-el wore
during man of steel there's one of zod's armor
suits which is a little more hardcore and then
the blue suit then we begin chapter 5 which is
titled all the king's horses which is a reference
to alfred's speech to batman saying that all the
king's horses won't be enough to march against
steppenwolf if his team isn't ready and can't work
together he also makes another red capes reference
reminding you of lex luthor's quote from batman v
superman the red capes are coming alfred mostly
uses it in a bullfighter reference though don't
wave the red cape at the bowl if you aren't ready
for him to charge the whole final boss fight goes
down very differently this whole third act fight
with superman also stopping at the bat cave before
he shows up to meet with alfred briefly before
he joins them after he arrives at the fight they
destroy steppenwolf they spank him super hard
but they do the big record scratch reversal type
of scene where the mother boxes are able to unify
start changing the planet before the flash can use
the speed force to help break their connection
everyone dies in this moment but the flash is
able to enter the speed force before the shock
wave hits him so you start to see him entering
the speed force running faster than he ever has
before in time begins to rewind everything rewinds
everyone's body parts start flying back onto their
bodies even superman's and this is all playing out
you notice darkseid has opened a boom tube and is
watching it all unfold like he's on some kind of
cosmic zoom call aquaman runs steppenwolf through
with his trident superman punches him through the
boom tube portal and as he's flying through wonder
woman chops his head off darkseid stopping the
head with the foot crushing it under his boot then
they have their epic gunslinger standoff moment
with the justice league and superman and declares
to dasad that he's going to bring his whole fleet
to earth to do things the old way that's his
very thanos fine i'll do it myself kind of speech
that's basically where they begin the epilogue
and i've already done an entire video about
the epilogue it's the last 30 minutes of the
movie it's huge there's all kinds of easter
eggs and a whole bunch of new scenes so i'll
put a link for that video at the end of this
and in the description but the one big thing that
we've learned like i said at the beginning of the
video is that in the justices gray black and white
version of the snyder cut they're going to have an
alternate joker scene so i will do a new video
for that when they release that cut of the film
because the movie is over four hours long there's
so many other things that i didn't discuss in the
video if there's any big questions or bigger
easter eggs that you want to talk about that
i didn't mention just write them below in the
comments i'll also do a video for the justice
league 2 and justice league 3 sequel stories that
zack snyder had planned to do and will probably
still eventually do in some sort of comic book
forum with jim lee maybe on the dc black label
that video should post in the next couple
of days at some point but while you wait for
everything click here for my full justice league
snyder cut ending and end credit scenes video
and click here for that brand new marvel
falcon and winter soldier episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!